c'est un véritable commando une équipe
bénévole de choc qui quadrillent les
quartiers de paisley et frappe à toutes
les portes
les efforts déployés par le parti
travailliste dans cette banlieue de
glasgow sont à la hauteur des enjeux
car la ville est sur le point de lui
échapper pour annoncer aux moquettes les
sondages ne sont pas très bons avoue
mark mcmorris alors on essaie de
rencontrer plus d'électeurs possibles
c'est notre troisième tournée au jour
siècle bourse emploi nouveauté la france
est d'autant plus mal que le candidat
travailliste sortant apaise les est un
poids lourd du parti et qu'il est sur le
point d'être délogé par une nouvelle
venue en politique
une étudiante d'à peine 20 ans la
candidate du parti national écossais
chef en fait sur la vague de
l'après-référendum et du réveil
nationaliste qu'il a suscité ce qu'on
écoute n'a jamais été bien représenté
les députés travaillistes nous ont
toujours déçu dit elle cette élection
est l'occasion de choisir des gens qui
vont vraiment aller défendre les
intérêts de l'école après avoir perdu en
septembre le référendum sur
l'indépendance le parti national
écossais s'inspire mettant de la
stratégie du bloc québécois en faisant
élire un maximum de députés au parlement
britannique
le snp entend obtenir de londres plus
d'autonomie pour les cos et pourquoi pas
quelques années à l'autre référendum
la stratégie semble fonctionner selon
les sondages le smp pourrait bien
remporter jeudi
la presque totalité des 59 sièges en
écosse et électrices s'apprêtent par
exemple à voter smp pour la première
fois de leur vie ils ont emmené d'abord
pas puisqu'on me snpi habituellement je
vois travailliste mais cette fois ci ce
sera snp fidèles parce qu'ils sont
vraiment en faveur de l'ecosse une vague
de fond qui fera mal au parti
travailliste
l'écossais toujours été un bassin de 40
à 50 sièges garantis pour les
travaillistes 17 analystes
sans ce coussin ils vont devoir
batailler encore plus fermes contre les
conservateurs ailleurs en
grande-bretagne alors que ces élections
s'annoncent extrêmement serrées
l'école se retrouve en position de force
le snp risque fort de détenir la balance
du pouvoir en mesure de monnayer son
appui à l'un ou l'autre des parties tous
s'accordent pour dire que c'est ici que
va se décider qui va former le prochain
gouvernement britannique
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
glasgow